Well,
welcome everyone.
Thank you for being here.
I'm excited to take some time today to talk about this new book and to introduce
you to the author and my friend Amy Karem.
Um,
she is the author of the book the China factor,
which we'll talk about today.
Uh,
for those of you who haven't read it yet,
it's been endorsed by Harvard,
Stanford and um,
the four words written by the chairman of the Silicon Valley Bank.
Um,
she was recently,
she and the book recently quoted in a Forbes article for those of you in the
room,
which is at the back,
uh,
that talked about,
Hillary and Donald,
for those of you here in the u s and how that,
this topic that she talks about is actually the one common factor between the
two of them as if you have a chance to read that article,
please do.
Um,
personally,
she was born and raised in,
uh,
bless you,
Canada,
uh,
which is how we know each other.
And,
um,
she started her interest in the area of international business and international
development through her education,
uh,
which she did both in French and in English.
Uh,
her major passion of course is bringing a high tech to emerging countries and
helping them with their developmental goals as well as ensuring that western
based companies develop their cultural Iq,
um,
to be successful in building those partnerships.
Um,
she's so passionate about this topic that she,
uh,
after working in the bay area,
with Cisco for many,
many years,
uh,
started her own consultancy practice and training organization.
She's a corporate instructor with Stanford on global expansion strategy and
competitive strategy and has also developed her own workshops,
uh,
as well.
So I'm excited to get started.
Please ask questions along the way if you've got questions or commentary.
Uh,
we're looking forward to this being interactive,
so thank you for your time.
We also have books at the back and Amy will be signing them later as well.
Well,
let's get started.
Welcome.
Happy to be here.
Um,
so tell me,
for those of us that haven't,
uh,
deep dive the book,
tell us about the China factor.
What's it about?
Um,
all right,
but before we get into the book,
I just wanted to take a survey.
How many of you have either worked in or with,
or for emerging markets?
Anybody familiar with?
Raise your hand.
Okay,
great.
We've got,
we've got a small handful.
All right,
super.
I just wanted to set the stage.
I'd love for this to be interactive.
So if you have comments,
we'd love to hear from you questions.
Um,
and just,
let's make this a,
a learning thing all across the board.
Um,
so about the China factor,
what I wanted to start off with is what it's not about necessarily a,
so it's not about how to do business in China,
although it would be useful for you if you were to use it for that purpose.
But what is it is,
uh,
the main,
the main intention of it is to equip Western based companies,
uh,
with strategies and tactics and knowledge in a better competing with emerging
entrance like those from China.
So China has risen a,
they're doing a great job.
They're a strong force in our economy and they do business differently.
And the,
uh,
the premise is that we as western based companies need to change our game a
little bit.
We need to know that emerging competitors,
uh,
have different approaches and we need to be more creative about that.
Um,
the other element is the innovation advantage and how do we protect or maintain
and evolve our innovation advantage.
And,
uh,
that's,
that's a big element in the book too.
So we'd take a look at some innovation models,
um,
and how,
uh,
how we can be innovating maybe a little bit differently or learning from each
other in terms of innovation.
So the book starts out with a little synopsis of what,
what really has happened,
right?
How to,
how to China become so strong.
What are the strengths and weaknesses of each side,
right?
The West and the east.
Uh,
and then we get into,
uh,
a comparison using the five part framework.
Uh,
this is how China or emerging competitors and,
or emerging competitors,
how they do business.
And then ultimately,
how can western based companies do business differently using that five part
framework.
And then we close with some detailed case studies just to give you an idea of
how all these elements come together.
Thank you for that.
And so share with the audience what this is based on.
Where did you,
where did the research come from?
What does that look like?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I worked at Cisco for over 10 years and a good part of those years,
about four of those years I led a competitive,
a sales support program that was sponsored by the CEO at the time.
So the fun part was,
uh,
Cisco was going to emerging markets in a big way.
They said emerging markets was important.
And also,
uh,
emerging competitors.
We're,
we're becoming a stronger force in,
in challenging us.
And so we created this program.
I was the global escalation point.
And so the,
the salespeople from around the world would tell me about their strategic deals
that they couldn't deal with on their own regionally,
uh,
that had to do with a competitors specifically from China.
And then the other part of the job was that I was to report,
um,
you know,
from a competitive intelligence perspective back to,
uh,
executive management saying,
hey,
this is what's happening in the field.
This is what we need to be more successful.
This is how we need to change or what resources we need to bring to bear in
order for this,
um,
you know,
for us to be more successful in this new global environment.
And so,
uh,
the results were,
opening.
It's just like,
wow,
this isn't business as usual.
It's not like some of our domestic competitors.
Um,
it's not a product superiority play anymore.
It's here.
It's like my box is better than your box,
so I'll win the business.
And that's not what was happening,
especially in emerging markets and especially with some emerging competitors.
So,
uh,
that was the catalyst for me to say,
wow,
this is not a trend.
This is not a blip.
This is,
I think,
you know,
here to stay.
And I wanted to share my learnings with other western based companies.
I know it's based on,
it's not just based on your time in Cisco though.
That's a yes.
Thank you.
So you,
right.
So that was the catalyst.
Um,
and then I left Cisco and I did a lot of research and it's based on a lot of
other companies as well.
You'll notice that the end,
even there's a case study of show May,
which is a China based,
a smartphone company,
a pinnacle engines,
which is the startup,
um,
who actually developed their products just for emerging markets and other
companies.
Like we talked about apple,
we talked about HP and we talk about intuit and it's also other industries as
well.
So I've,
I've tried to pepper it in with other,
other data points as well.
For sure.
It's you,
so you just talked about some eyeopening,
uh,
surprises in some of your work as a thread.
Do you want to give some examples of those?
Maybe share a couple?
Sure,
sure.
So,
uh,
first is the severe price discounting and that's no shocker,
right?
Most of us know that that's generally a pretty
consistent market penetration strategy,
but there was really no bottom to it.
Excuse me.
So I,
I encountered a lot of escalations where they'd say,
Hey,
my competitors just discounted me by another,
you know,
25%.
I need,
I need approval for another,
another discount.
And so we realized that that that wasn't going to be a successful strategy for
either either competitor and even for the customer.
It wasn't a winning game.
So that was one big thread.
The other was financing,
which we didn't really get into very much as a Western base company.
And,
and that's a real helpful tool for emerging customers.
Um,
so you know,
this,
this competitor would,
uh,
help them with financing and to an extreme degree,
right?
Sometimes they would,
uh,
help finance over a very long period of time.
And that was a real great value to these emerging markets customers.
And then another huge trend,
a huge element that came up was politics,
the use of politics,
uh,
to influence business decisions.
And we're like,
Whoa,
where did that come from?
Like,
what do we do about that?
You know,
I would get escalated complaints,
you know,
from emerging markets.
It's like we've been working this deal for two years.
We had an bag and the 11th hour,
you know,
they just said it was,
uh,
an influence from above.
We have no idea where it came from.
Right.
And it was government to government influencing for business decisions at a more
granular level.
Yeah.
So politics is interesting and something that Google obviously is,
had,
um,
some experience with as well.
So do you want to talk a little bit more about some of the,
the practical things that you had to think about and actually do for,
for success with?
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
So politics is a huge element of,
of the whole strategy.
And so because it was so important in the way we had to re vector our strategy,
uh,
so another part of my job was to chain the sales teams worldwide on how to
position a visa vi certain types of competitors.
And so,
uh,
in in the book I outlined five part framework as I mentioned,
and I added,
um,
for those of you who are business geeks,
four p's of marketing,
right?
Product Price,
place promotion.
Uh,
so I created the fifth p,
which is politics,
right?
So I had the five p's of global marketing framework and politics.
So back to your specific question.
Um,
it does,
it happens at the,
at a high level and you have your executive management making pretty big
decisions,
right?
In terms of market access.
So because this has become such a big world,
but it's small at the same time,
uh,
we need market access.
We want to play in other people's sandboxes as I say.
Um,
but there's certain rules and there are certain limitations that we need to
encounter.
And you folks know better than I,
right?
When Google pulled out of China in 2010,
right,
for censorship reasons,
et Cetera,
that was a big decision.
And the implications were,
you know,
they're a huge,
right.
You could have affected maybe like 1.4,
1.5 billion people in terms of access to knowledge,
but there were really good reasons.
And those were the,
uh,
the boundaries within which a Western based company decided that they did not
want to operate.
However,
right?
Recent headlines is there going back in,
So market access is really important.
And,
and reach is really important.
So the political element is knowing that coopertition is,
is the new element.
It's not that new,
but it's,
it's an integral part of a strategy going forward,
right?
It's,
it's not us versus them.
I call it dusk a little bit,
right?
When you combine the two words,
it's how do we all play together,
um,
within our own,
uh,
you know,
boundaries and,
and desirables,
um,
to get ultimately the success that we need.
So that's,
that's it at a high level.
Um,
and then how do you,
how do we at the working level,
uh,
deal with politics and politics even happens at the organizational level,
right?
And,
and generally there's a pretty negative connotation to politics.
Um,
but what I'm trying to say in the book is it's really important.
We can't ignore it anymore and we,
we need to embrace it and apply it.
So how do we apply it from a sales perspective?
Uh,
what we did was educated,
we educated the sales teams on some of the,
uh,
tools available from the u s government,
for example.
And the local governments in,
uh,
the,
you know,
different countries,
how can they engage with their own government to help influence their own sales
locally?
So reaching out to the consulates,
how do you get involved?
How do you know that some of these deal opportunities are happening early on in
the game?
How do you escalate a,
some,
maybe unfair trade issues that you're experiencing so that there's maybe some
intervention sooner than later and it's not at the 11th hour when we oftentimes
hear about it.
And then we also organizationally changed,
uh,
and were able to convince the senior vice president of government affairs to
shift the focus from just a policy perspective to um,
helping with sales objectives,
right?
So using that influence that they have in the government affairs group for more
of the,
uh,
the end result in,
in terms of numbers and not just policy.
And that was really effective too.
Uh,
we went to Washington DC and we escalated some of our concerns.
So there's a lot we can do.
And,
and I think it's really,
uh,
the point of learning from each other.
It's okay,
this is the situation.
How can you mirror and then tap into your own resources?
You talk you some great examples in the book.
I think it'd be interesting for this audience tear of your perspective on how
Western based companies could potentially evolve or change things that to think
about doing differently.
Yeah.
So I,
there's a list,
of course we all love lists and there's a list of 13 things,
recommendations that we can do.
And ironically it ended up on chapter 13.
So I think that's a really good luck thing for,
um,
some cultures.
Mine maybe,
but,
um,
so very simply go global.
A lot of times a Western based companies have been hesitant and I don't mean
Google,
let's,
let's just set a story.
There's a lot of companies that have already gone global and get the global
thing,
but I'm just generalizing here.
It's don't be afraid to go global.
It's,
we need to,
um,
the second part is,
okay,
while you're out there,
you know,
let's,
let's move out of emerging markets being a novelty.
And I think a lot of western based companies dabble in emerging markets.
Oh yeah.
It's really cool.
Let's,
let's try it out.
Let's throw a few people and in there and see how it works out.
Oh,
not making the Roi that we need got to pull out,
right?
It needs to be a longer term investment.
It needs to be a commitment and you need to know that it's,
it's not just a temporary thing.
Um,
other things like product development,
make sure that your product development is catering or customizing to local
customer needs.
We can't just recycle.
It's not,
oh,
this is a mature product in this market.
Let's just throw it over the fence and see if they're going to like our old
product.
You had a great example that we talked about recently on that and something that
you were working with,
with Cisco when you were,
when they were bringing product to market to your mind,
we talked about.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and that's,
yeah,
that's the other challenge with a really successful innovative companies,
right?
Who have a print premium based product is we're really proud of our innovations
and our products.
And I was hosting a,
some ministers from an African country and,
uh,
they nicely,
politely sat through the presentation at the executive briefing center and we
were talking about how great our super core router was and all the features and
functionality and it's the best out there.
And,
and then at the end they just,
you know,
they asked us a question politely thank you for the presentation and,
um,
how,
how does your product deal with power surges,
what and um,
right.
And so in a lot of emerging countries,
uh,
the power goes on and off because it's inconsistent and when the power comes on,
there is a power surge and sometimes the power surge is so strong it comes
through and blows up the equipment.
So we're asking them to invest millions of dollars in this super duper core
router.
And,
uh,
we haven't helped them protect that investment by knowing,
you know,
a very small detail of their needs.
Right.
So of course,
the presenter was caught off guard,
hadn't done their homework,
didn't really know what the true customer needs were.
And,
uh,
you know,
we didn't get to answer the question really well,
so thank you for bringing that up.
And so it's,
it's these little nuances,
right?
Do you look through the list and you're like,
yes,
I know that,
but do we really know these things?
Do we really think of these things before we just jump in?
Right,
right down to the execution detail,
uh,
loosely.
How do we think about how do we develop product for countries where or,
and,
or people where we are not right?
How do we do that effectively?
Is that remotely close?
Yeah,
really good question.
And,
uh,
whether it's good or bad,
really it's the business case that makes it happen or not.
And uh,
that,
that was a little bit of the challenge that I've encountered in the past is,
um,
you can say,
you know,
emerging markets really needs this.
And then management will say,
show me the numbers,
give me the estimates.
What is the,
what are the forecasts?
So if you can give them some sort of revenue projections,
a but then the,
the quick answer is going to be,
oh,
but that's so small relative to our larger revenue stream.
So my other angle to that is the strategic importance of addressing that market
with that product or that solution.
Right?
So it's the opportunity cost of not being there and a lot of companies are
punished and if they're not right when you're a slow to market,
and I talk a little bit about this in there,
it's time to market is,
is really important and you dilly dally and think about and analyze too long
because there are so many other competitors out there ready and waiting and,
and addressing that market.
So even if you do decide eventually,
sure we're going to play,
you may have missed that window and it's,
it's the longer term view.
Um,
you know,
you asked me last question,
but recommendations,
it's really comes down to really committing and,
and having that longer term strategic view that,
that enables that.
I think what's interesting about your point is as a developer,
so someone who is in product development as opposed to the sales side,
you actually talk about something in your book about relationships and you know,
patients in the long term and how important that is.
So I wonder how much that plays into sort of the development lifecycle and
thinking about making sure that your relationships are long term and you're in
there for the long haul.
Yeah,
huge.
Yeah.
Especially,
and then when you develop those relationships,
you get that real,
um,
you know,
uh,
on the street data that helps you support that case.
You talked about right at the very beginning,
you've talked about the innovation advantage.
So tell us how Western based companies can maintain the innovation advantage.
Yeah.
Uh,
thanks for,
for coming back to that.
Uh,
so the key crux of it is the innovation vantage is the,
the,
the coveted prize,
the white flag at the top of the mountain.
Right at the beginning of the book,
we talk about strengths and weaknesses of each side,
but ultimately
every,
I'm generalizing,
but right.
Every,
every company and,
uh,
east to west really wants to be innovative because that's really where the next,
phase of growth comes from.
Um,
and so we see contingents of,
of emerging,
um,
folks coming to silicon valley wanting to learn the secret of how are,
how silicon valley innovative,
how do you do it?
How do you become creative with the ideas that we have to also be creative too.
We have to be innovative at being innovative.
So you can't just the rest on your laurels.
Uh,
this whole concept of innovation is evolving and as more players from different
backgrounds are becoming innovative,
they're bringing different business models.
So we talk about five different business models and a couple of them are
business model innovation,
right?
That's coming from the east.
What do they really good at?
They're really good at commercializing things.
Um,
and again,
I'm going to generalize.
We're really good at making things really cool things,
but they're really good at making money yet from really cool things or even
making money from,
okay,
cool things.
But it's that whole business model innovation.
And then we also talk about a supply chain or process innovation.
I mean there's the reputation of manufacturing.
They've got it down to t,
you know,
so a one,
a venture capitalist who I interviewed in the book said,
you know,
all this business about bringing manufacturing back to America.
We don't have the efficiencies,
we don't have the ecosystems yet to do that.
And some of the eastern countries do.
Right.
Um,
and we need to either establish that ecosystem or just understand that,
right?
Like that there's,
there's a different source of innovation happening out there.
Yeah.
I'm just generalizing to be more encompassing.
Like it's,
it's based out of China and I don't want to just pigeon hole China as being the
manufacturing giant because they're evolving out of that.
And other countries are,
are,
are growing into that.
Right?
Bangladesh and Vietnam are becoming so,
but I mean it's even humorous to see an emerging country like Mexico outsourcing
to China or they have done in the past outsourcing their manufacturing to China.
It's like their unemployment,
unemployment's high,
why can't it is right.
It is so efficient there.
They're so smart about it.
And let's not even think about the shipping costs right alone.
So it Matt.
So that's what I'm saying.
All I'm saying is let's get more creative.
Let's figure out what's our,
what's our innovation two.
Dot.
Oh.
Like,
or five dot.
Or whatever the revenue that we're on.
How are we going to,
you know,
step up our game and learn from others as well.
So you,
we talked a little yesterday about,
um,
a company companies that you thought were doing this well or an example of a
model that's doing this well.
Are doing a good,
oh yeah,
let's talk about your own,
uh,
Hugo Barra.
Okay.
So shall may recruited a Hugo Barra.
That's one of the 13,
right?
Talent is one of the recommendations.
They recruited your own,
uh,
Hugo Barra who is running the android,
product line here.
They made a VP global of shall may,
uh,
they used their phone is based on the android platform,
um,
but they've been criticized for it looking like an iPhone.
Okay.
So they're doing the mix and match and then they've applied it to their Chinese
market.
And,
um,
they're,
they've capitalized on the local,
you know,
the,
the Chinese social media phenomenon.
I think it's WeChat that everybody's a all over right.
And,
um,
they have fans right there cut.
They're not customers,
they're called fans.
And there's direct access to the fan base and they tell them what's working with
the phone.
So,
wow.
They just shaved off millions of r and d because the actual users end users are
telling them what they need to have improved.
They have like real time,
like almost weekly software updates,
right?
So they're not waiting for the next,
you know,
iPhone six s to come out in eight months with lineups around the corner.
Right?
There's that regular updates,
which is also,
you know,
the android platform that enables that.
So they've,
they've adapted,
they've taken innovation from all over,
including the talent,
right?
Put it in a different market,
use the local market dynamics to make it super successful.
And what I really like about this example too is they are not,
uh,
they're very shrewd about knowing that this model isn't going to necessarily
work as they go to other countries,
uh,
as they do their market expansion strategy.
So for example,
in the Philippines,
they're not,
uh,
they're,
they don't do a lot of chat,
right?
They don't do a lot of Twitter and they know that.
So they're like,
okay,
that's not going to be a success element for us.
Nor is the fact that our CEO is a rock star in China.
Right?
So that's not going to be,
how are we going to modify our market expansion strategy to be successful
elsewhere?
So yeah,
that's,
that's just one example of,
of doing a combined strategy.
How worried should western companies be about Ip?
It's a big deal.
Uh,
everybody should be worried about it.
Eastern companies should be worried about it too.
Um,
and that's,
that's the ongoing debate.
In fact,
there was another headline recently about the word iPhone being used for another
product.
I think they were just leather goods in China and it was in the courts.
I hear some head nods,
right?
Uh,
there was a debate over many years and their court said it was okay.
So then you get into intellectual,
uh,
sorry,
international law and regulation,
and then sometimes you bring in the,
the World Trade Organization.
What does the World Trade Organization say or do?
But then you have to figure out,
does that person or you know,
does that country or that competitor care,
right?
What are the implications?
So yes,
uh,
we need to care.
And in fact,
uh,
Michelle Lee is doing a really great job of that and she's quoted in the book
too.
Um,
she's heading up the whole intellectual property,
uh,
issue,
for the u s government.
And,
uh,
you know,
and this comes up with the whole,
uh,
TPP,
um,
issue,
right?
The Trans Pacific partnership agreement.
And a lot of people saying this is great.
And then a lot of people are saying,
we better be careful because what's that going to mean for,
for our own protection?
And it goes both ways.
Right?
So that's,
and that's comes back to politics as well.
There's,
there's that back and forth in terms of protectionist measure measures.
Um,
I know recently of course,
you know,
and you,
as well,
China has pulled back on market access to a lot of western based countries,
um,
for different reasons of course.
But it's,
it's not all in trying to say it's,
it's both.
It goes both ways.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the government is looking at it I guess is the short answer and uh,
be very prudent and careful.
Yeah.
So in what way can governments be helpful and play a role and in what way can
they not be helpful?
Okay.
Uh,
so governments,
uh,
are there for you.
The,
uh,
the,
trade groups,
the trade commissions,
they have contingents that take you out and help you,
uh,
with market access and they give you the lay of the land.
They give you contacts,
right.
And they give you the heads up on what yes.
What no to do.
Um,
and one of the challenges with that as well is that,
uh,
we have a very fair government and they don't play favorites.
So the extreme right,
the extent to which they will help,
uh,
companies has to be very,
is very limited because they have to be very fair to everyone.
They can't favor any particular company in a particular industry.
So it gets very tricky and they're very aware of that challenge,
uh,
because it's other,
other countries' governments are much more aggressive,
uh,
when it does come to,
you know,
presenting a certain company abroad.
Um,
so I guess they're looking at it,
but it's very difficult to change based on our democratic fairness system.
Um,
and what was the second part of that?
How can they not be helpful?
Yeah,
that's helpful.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and they need to just get more involved.
To be honest.
There's a lot of groups.
So for example,
in the high tech industry,
uh,
they have even competitors have been coming together to share some of their
challenges and their complaints and going as,
um,
as a cooperative group to the government to present some of these challenges and
ask them to make some changes and how they present or represent us abroad.
I mean quite simply,
even with the trade agreements,
what,
how are we really leveraging those,
like,
uh,
like China and other companies or countries do.
Um,
so there is,
there are ways that we can step it up,
but I think it's,
it's a,
it's a slow ongoing process.
Companies that you think are just not doing this all,
or did you see examples of this not working well?
Yeah,
sometimes we're just too arrogant and we don't,
I,
I'm going to generalize.
I don't want to name names,
but yeah,
as,
uh,
as Western based companies,
we don't get it sometimes.
And,
um,
and that know,
I talk about Cultural Iq and the book and again,
we've all been very sensitized to that,
especially here in the u s and in Silicon Valley.
But it's really taking it to that next,
uh,
next step and really appreciating the local nuances before we just dive in
because they'll quickly,
you know,
throw us out and,
and then we,
we look baffled when,
when it doesn't,
um,
it doesn't work.
I'm just,
I'm just thinking back to like,
just even a stint that I did in South Africa and,
uh,
we went in and literally for two days now I did a little bit of meetings,
did it,
I'm embarrassed to say a 24 hour safari.
Yes.
We did see almost all the animals that we needed to see in 24 hours.
It was ours and we flew out and we felt really good about it.
Um,
but we didn't get the business,
you know,
it's just why,
why didn't they?
Well,
because you can't,
you can't just swoop in,
fly on.
Right.
And,
uh,
expect to build that relationship instantly just because we're,
we've got brand equity.
There was a piece in the question about financing and government involvement in
financing,
specifically using China as an example.
And whether that's a model that will continue or whether the model will actually
look very different.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
there's,
there was a second part we'll get to too.
It was really interesting.
Uh,
so yeah,
let's get it to the front.
I'm glad you brought that up because this is a really huge,
uh,
challenge for Western based Con,
countries and companies.
Uh,
so the good news is,
and,
and I,
and I'm happy to talk about this because I've,
I've been very passionate about it,
is we have a lot of,
uh,
international development banks that can tap into this,
right?
So I would get the complaints,
it's like,
hey,
how do I compete with this?
There's financing and they just gave this company $10 billion over this amount
of time.
Like,
sorry,
we don't,
we don't have that kind of cash to give out,
nor would we,
because that's not what we do.
However,
let's look at these programs.
So there are international development banks that you can tap into.
You can allocate maybe half a head count or one or two head counts for it.
And all you do is comb the projects that are coming up.
There was cash waiting to be had.
And it's,
it's really bridging that private sector to that customer in the emerging
country and saying,
hey,
we can help you with that development and let us help you fill out the forms and
Whoa,
well,
ah,
you just helped your customer finance the purchase of your equipment.
And by the way,
you just establish a relationship because you're helping them execute in ways
that they may not have.
So that's just one small way to do it.
Um,
and then it's also companies can get a little bit more assertive with risk
taking.
Uh,
so Cisco had know Cisco capital and we were very conservative about who was
Cisco capital,
um,
put money out to.
But eventually we,
we came to the realization that hey,
we're really serious about emerging markets and perhaps we are,
you know,
ready to have a fund,
a special strategic fund for key business.
That is a really important for us to win.
And we're going to be very diligent about assessing who we lend that money too.
But Hey,
why not?
Right.
And that just shows a little bit more of a commitment.
Now let's get back to your question.
You also talked about pockets in the world that would influence product
development because of the financing?
Yeah.
Yes.
The quick answer is yes.
So she's essentially saying base based on local market needs and trends,
especially from a technology usage.
Is that going to f,
uh,
influence product development,
locally and it's not going to be centralized,
right?
It's innovation not going to be centralized in,
in one place.
Absolutely.
Yes.
I say very emphatically.
That's the point.
We need to start looking at that and localizing innovation,
uh,
based on local customer needs.
How are people using this material like today?
Yeah,
so I,
I did take a lot of pride in the fact that this is,
uh,
I wanted it to be a practical guide,
like a toolbox for business people to,
to kind of go through and see what they can implement.
So,
um,
it's a checklist.
It's,
there's a framework inside.
I even have like a,
a rough template in the back where you can get your folks together and
strategize about your next global expansion,
um,
endeavor and ask yourself certain questions.
Uh,
but I'm also giving workshops and I like to facilitate the discussion and get
the ball rolling.
And either a lot of times it's at corporations,
uh,
with similar teams that are trying to build their global expansion strategy and
it's stirring the pot and getting them to think about certain elements.
And,
and,
um,
I love seeing the,
the thread of influence,
right?
So it's,
it's looking at the five p's framework and as simple as it may sound,
uh,
when you look at the competitive,
dynamic that might rebut your strategy,
it really shows you how you might want to reconsider and how one,
um,
you know,
decision in one element or one area will influence,
uh,
the other areas.
So it's,
it's that puppeteering and really thinking it through,
uh,
through the workshops and the courses that it really makes,
you know,
makes an impact at the end.
Great.
Um,
just maybe on a closing note,
um,
there's so much in this book and it's,
and it's a wonderful to read and they're controversial pieces and one can
sometimes leave feeling worried and or challenged,
but you are so positive.
So,
um,
tell us what,
what makes you so positive just about this topic?
Um,
I think the reinforcement from industry,
from people that have lived at,
um,
people who were there,
you mentioned 10 Wilcox who wrote the foreword.
I mean,
just,
just the validation from people out there that are like,
this is this.
Yes,
this is a need.
This needs to be done.
And the idea that we all do need to work together.
The idea that it's coopertition,
it's no longer a competition game.
We need to learn how to learn from each other,
uh,
equally.
Um,
and,
and that's also playing each other's sandboxes and learning how to do that
respectfully given our are different boundaries and limitations.
So I just,
I just think it's necessary.
We just need to figure out how to,
to recalibrate and everybody will be successful.
Great.
Thank you.
Well,
thank you for that.
Amy's going to stick around a little bit to answer questions for those of you
that are in the room and would like to stay.
Thank you so much for coming in.
Thank you for having me.
I had a good time.
Great,
thanks.
Yeah.